you're working in australia so what what
what are you working on
i am working on baslerman's uh movie
about elvis presley austin butler is
playing elvis presley and here let me
show you let me show you the horrible
haircut i have to have in order to
portray colonel tom parker okay check
out check out this horrible okay do you
see that
look at that thing wait wait wait sit
down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what i really want to do is just have a
little tuft of hair right here and then
a big big beard and then everybody would
think i'm graham norton yes
it's uncanny
you can play me in the biopic
that's about as famous as again because
elvis that was kind of that was an
established view as a i was gonna say
adult movie star but that makes it sound
wrong
[Laughter]
a movie star as an adult i mean that was
kind of your your big breakout role
wasn't it it really yeah it really was
i mean um but the thing about it is is
that when you're playing the coca-cola
can because everybody knows you know
it's you and you got that way at the
time
sarah palin was really well known
everybody knew what she looked like and
sounded like
it's very difficult because that puts
you get the parameters there that you
cannot go outside of that or you start
losing right but we i only had to be
two-dimensional you had to portray this
person
i had but i had the i had help with the
screenplay in the story sure you know i
had a lot going for it and it's so odd
that this thing kind of crops up in your
life because one of your very first
acting roles was with the real elvis
yeah it was 62 something like that it
was the world's fair
and uh i was 10 years old and
i got this job you know to play this kid
that kicks elvis in the shins too yeah
you walk
in the chat there i am kicking away he
wants to meet a girl a nurse so he
figures you know he'll get this kid to
injure him a little bit
and i kind of hit him a little too hard
you know but he pays me 50 cents and
then later on when she's with him i run
into him at the fair and i say hey
mister you're going to kick you in the
shin again
and she's like look at it he goes get
away you don't get away but i said you
can do it for a quarter i'll give you a
take a quarter
did you get the
film wow that's better than the monkey
one
did you get the did you get that it was
elvis i mean no i i
i was my first brush with celebrity
though i i never i'd never i was just a
kid you know was he like yeah he was
great he was really a nice man and
he he uh he came on the set in the car
and uh
there were you know the world's fair was
just opening and so there's a lot of
people there and all of a sudden he came
on the set and uh
maybe two three thousand women just went
they just jumped the car
and he had to bail out and come in a
different way and i thought
this guy must really be famous
tell me this when you went i think the
the first time you went was it to do a
tv show 1967 or something 45 65 and is
that when you met elvis for the first
time i met elvis presley
i was there
don't try and compete
so i uh i got there and um you know it
was wonderful we were staying in the
gene auto hotel you know on sunset strip
at the time and she naughty was there
saw him standing there you know i mean
god you know this is unbelievable my
first year in show business and then i
had to go to paramount studios for the
song for something and they said elvis
presley's going to be there tomorrow and
he would like to meet you
i thought elvis presley wants to meet me
it was it was unbelievable and i went
there
and you know to go and see about the
song and they said elvis is filming
and um
you know
once once they stop the filming you you
go in
so i did and then they closed the doors
again and i'm standing in the back there
with the memphis mafia
these guys that worked for him and he's
in this little mock helicopter with this
girl and um
and they did the scene you know and i'm
like look at my god it is alves presley
and then he they said okay cut and he
looked across and went
you know and
i was like you know looking at these
fellas with me they said elvis is waving
at you don't wave back
so anyway so he gets out of this
helicopter and he starts walking towards
me well i had a single record out at the
moment it was my third single
uh called with these hands it was a
ballad it's a beautiful song and elvis
is walking towards me going with his
hand oh my god i will cling to you right
and he's going um
and i thought
my god if the boys back home could see
me now you know
[Applause]
and karate to you
does that mean anything to you yeah oh
it does oh good oh tell all
well he'd like to do it he loved karate
yes and um
his moves on stage
um later on
came from karate and he just he was just
really into it
i met him in las
vegas um
i had two
dancers in my show two beautiful lady
dancers it was us three women i hear
this
and
he i think he kind of likes one of those
ladies
so he came backstage and said can i
watch the sofa and i said sure
and he watched and everything then he
invited us all over
and we went over to this spectacular i
mean i've never seen his face like that
his suite it was just incredible
incredible
and um
we're kind of sitting there i'm next to
alice cooper
we're sitting there
chubby checkers
alice cooper
um some porn star i i can't remember
which way some really you know right at
the moment good ones was linda lovely
[Applause]
british comedian as well
oh yeah
but we're all just kind of sitting there
and he's
disappeared so we're kind of trying to
chat and suddenly
the door flies open like they are
yeah
and he's in the room in full
you know dress
and then it was like the peter sellers
movie where the guy comes out of the
closet to fight him you know
yeah and he suddenly
some guy i guess his teacher you heard
and he came from over here
and all of us are going
gee that's great
wow
you do this every night what do you say
it was just i couldn't believe it i love
your life
i couldn't believe it
if i if i was elvis presley i think that
would be my chat up strategy
i don't think i bothered with the kung
fu bit of
martial arts i'm elvis yeah they come in
and all forget it
he was a nice man yeah
[Laughter]
in terms of is the story about graceland
true
uh me
raiding graceland you mean yeah when i
was still alive it was 1975
and
we were in memphis
and stephen and i wanted to go to an
all-night diner it's around 3 00 a.m we
got in a taxi
the taxi cab says yeah there's one right
out by elvis's house
alvin's house
you know where elvis lives
take us there right now
taxi driver took us
to graceland
and i got out i saw there was some
lights on in the house because you could
see the house wasn't far dry
gates were locked the stone wall
i looked at steve i said steve i'm going
in
and the taxi driver said hey man don't
go in there they got big dogs over there
don't go over that wall
i said well
when's the opportunity gonna come again
i jumped over the wall
ran up the drive
got to the front door
i was just about to knock on the front
door and a security guy came out of the
bushes
and he said can i help you
and very casually like yeah
i said yes is elvis is elvis here
i said well
elvis is in las vegas
i said okay well
can you tell him
and i i generally don't like to do this
but
bruce springsteen was here
and
he may not know who that is but i was
just on the cover of time and newsweek
for for you young folks they were
magazines
they said yeah and and could you tell me
yeah i'll tell elvis and
then he came down and walked me out and
let me out of that's as close i ever got
to always
[Applause]
[Music]
you